you
go Morgan good morning the Novation
Nobel Committee has decided that the
Nobel Peace Prize for 2009 is to be
avoided to President Barack Obama for
his extraordinary efforts to strengthen
international diplomacy and cooperation
between people's the committee has
attached special importance to Obama's
vision and work for a world without
nuclear weapons
Obama has as president created a new
international climate politic
multilateral diplomacy has regained
central position with emphasis on the
role that United Nations and other
international institutions can play
dialogue and negotiations are preferred
as instrument for resolving even the
most difficult conflicts the vision of a
world free from nuclear arms has
powerful stimulated disarmament and arms
control negotiations
thanks to Obama's initiative the United
States is now playing a more
constructive role in meeting the great
climatic challenges the world is
confronting democracy and human rights
are to be strengthened only very rarely
has a person to the same extent as Obama
captured the world's attention and given
his people hoped for a better future his
diplomacy is founded in the concept that
those who are to lead the world must do
so on the basis of values and attitudes
that are shared by the majority of the
world's population for 108 years the
nobies Nobel Committee has sought to
stimulate precisely the international
policy and those attitudes forbid Obama
is now the world's leading spokesman the
committee endorses Obama's appeal that
now is the time for all of us to take
over chair or responsibility for a
global response to global challenges
thank you
you